what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and secret Invasion has come and gone we
got the finale for it this week and
interestingly enough it was rated the
worst finale on Rotten Tomatoes out of
any Marvel Studios Disney Plus show
which does kind of come as a shocker but
go ahead and let us know your thoughts
about the finale and the series as a
whole in the comments down below now
whether you like the series or not there
were a lot of really important things
that happened including a big X-Men
Easter egg it looks like Marvel Studios
is Paving the way for the X-Men mutants
to become a major part of the MCU
possibly beginning before the Multiverse
Saga ends now we do know that most
likely the story for the X-Men and the
mutants is really going to begin in
Phase seven this is when Marvel Studios
will really take a deep dive into the
story of individual mutants and then the
X-Men team as a whole but that doesn't
mean that the story and the foundation
for the X-Men and the new mutants isn't
going to begin before then in fact this
X-Men Easter egg that was discovered in
the secret Invasion show seems to be
pretty significant and it kind of points
to the fact that Fury might actually
lead a new X-Men team or at least be
associated with them in some way shape
or form because obviously we want
Professor Xavier to be the leader of the
X-Men team but since secret Invasion
kind of deemed aliens or anybody born
off-world to be the enemies at the end
of secret Invasion and since basically
the whole entire world now knows that
aliens attack the president of the
United States this does set up the
premise for the mutant storyline of
where the humans fear the mutants and do
not want to co-exist with them this
would have Charles Xavier fighting for
mutant rights alongside of Human Rights
and this would have Magneto not caring
about the humans at all and thinking
mutants are superior and wanting to
essentially take out the humans both
views could involve Nick Fury Nick Fury
could be an advocate for the mutants
because he's worked with a lot of super
humans before and he could also so be
dealing with the threat of Magneto of
course because that's what he does he
deals with Earthly and Universal threats
and it seems like the old Nick Fury is
back now and he's made up with his wife
and that's actually where the Easter egg
comes from his wife in episode 4
actually we can see that secret Invasion
gave us a little nod to the X-Men in
episode 4 in the home of Nick Fury and
Priscilla Fury or vara's home in the
background we can see a framed picture
however this isn't a framed picture per
se but it's a framed book cover front
and back of a book that Priscilla wrote
and it's very very clever how Marvel did
this and it's very clever that Marvel
didn't even mention this it's simply
just in the background it was never
addressed but if you take a close look
on the back of the book cover on the
left side we can see what looks to be a
blue X and there is even a circle kind
of going around it as well this looks
like the Classic X-Men logo the blue X
with a blue ring around it and the
yellow in between it even does look like
on the back of the book cover that it
does have a little ring going around it
as well now here's the real kicker
here's what the book is about we can see
on the right side that the title of this
book is decoding the super human gene
this is a direct reference to the mutant
Gene the gene that gives people
superpowers the x-gene the mutant Gene
that gives Wolverine the ability to heal
Professor X the ability to read minds
and use telekinesis Magneto the ability
to control metal we know how this works
that is what Priscilla has been studying
she published a book on it decoding the
Superhuman Gene and what's really
interesting is that the next Nick Fury
movie is going to be the marbles in
which Kamala Khan aka Miss Marvel is
going to be a huge part of that movie
obviously but she's a mutant Marvel
Studios and now Marvel Comics have
retcon kamalakon to be a mutant in the
comics and Marvel Studios in the MCU are
saying that she is a mutant as well she
has that mutant superhuman Gene this is
huge and the biggest part is the direct
connection of Nick Fury to the mutants
now his wife is seemingly doing some
leading research on the mutant Gene and
it looks like now him and his wife are
closer than ever and she even says that
she has to come back to earth to start
doing more research this could be the
research that she was talking about the
research on the Superhuman Gene she
could be the start or at least part of
the start to the storyline of the
mutants coming into the MCU and if we
think about it it really does make sense
for Fury to be involved if Fury is back
to his normal self and it really does
seem like he is then Fury is going to be
keeping track of enhanced individuals
this is what he did before this is how
he got in contact with Iron Man and this
is how he essentially assembled The
Avengers keeping his eye out on enhanced
individuals and by now he's worked with
enough in enhanced individuals to know
that some are going to be good and some
are going to be bad and it's his job to
really attend to both make sure the good
guys are fighting alongside him and
helping him defend Earth and making sure
on the other end that the bad guys don't
wipe out Earth and I wouldn't be
surprised if Professor Xavier actually
meets the wife of Nick Fury due to all
of her research and the books that she
is literally publishing on the
Superhuman Gene that could be the big
connection right there between Nick Fury
and professor Charles Xavier Nick Fury's
wife she is clearly in the field in
which Professor Xavier is going to be in
the field as well and that's essentially
what Professor Xavier builds his life on
he entered Bard College in New York at
age 16 and he got his bachelor's degree
in biology within two years that he was
there he then went to Oxford University
in England and he earned his degree in
genetics and biophysics so he's a
genetics expert and scholar and that is
essentially What It Seems like Nick
Fury's wife is doing she is studying
genetics she has studied the Superhuman
Gene and that seems like it would get
the attention of Charles Xavier a
scholar out there discovering and doing
work with the Superhuman Gene that is
literally what he studies that is right
up his alley and also of course we know
that he's a mutant himself now as far as
how the story is actually going to pan
out we do know that before the
Multiverse Saga ends we're not going to
see too many New Mutants not the actual
new Mutant team but new Mutant slash
X-Men entering the MCU we'll see a few
and we'll see some hints in Easter eggs
like this but we know that mostly it's
going to be focused on the original
X-Men like Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
returning in Deadpool 3. plus not to
mention a lot of the other X-Men that
are going to be returning in Deadpool 3
as well Charles Xavier Magneto Jean Gray
supposed to return Cyclops is supposed
to return there's been talks about the
original Fantastic Four showing up as
well in which yes this is the Multiverse
Saga it is focused on the very variants
especially Deadpool 3 it seems like but
from what we've been told they're not
just going to show up in Deadpool 3 they
will again return in Avengers Secret
Wars which makes sense we're going to
have universes collided into each other
we're going to have incursions and we're
going to see variants interacting with
each other which is really what we're
all waiting for but it does sound like
the original X-Men will occupy the
Multiverse Saga and then when we jump
into the new saga in Phase 7 it'll focus
on our new X-Men and of course the
Fantastic Four but this is a huge Easter
egg and it could tell us that Nick Fury
is going to be involved with the mutants
as well just like he was with the
Avengers but go ahead and let us know
what you think about this Easter egg in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe to stay up
to date on the MCU and if you subscribe
and leave a comment you're entered in
our giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick a winner at the end
of each month you can also find us on
patreon you can check out our website
and find us on escort as well and of
course you can follow us on Instagram
and Twitter as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf
me